okay
welcome to google hangout uh live from
the aaas
i'm here today with two anthropologists
rachel caspari and karen rosenberg
rachel's from michigan uh excuse me from
central michigan university and karen is
from the university of delaware and
we're here today to talk about scars the
scars of human evolution
we are the most successful primates
we've evolved all sorts of great
adaptations such as the big brain
upright walking we live for a long time
but all these adaptations that make us
so special
have also taken a toll on us there's a
cost to these adaptations so today we're
going to do a live chat a live webcast
where you can ask questions of karen and
rachel to talk about what the toll has
been what has been the cost of these so
if you have a question for them please
post them at the bottom of the page and
we will get to them we'll try to get to
most of them we won't be able to get to
all of them but we'll get to as many as
we possibly can
and they will go ahead and try to answer
them um
so thanks for joining us we're going to
go ahead and start asking our questions
um so rachel just from the beginning why
don't you go ahead and tell us about
some of the adaptations that we talked
about yesterday in the sessions
uh such as the big brain the things that
make us special and what the toll has
been that they've taken on us
okay well
as you've just mentioned the two major
adaptations that make humans different
from any other primate species is that
we are bipeds and that we have these
very big brains that are associated with
culture that we assume
that we assume
these big brains are associated with
abstract thinking and language perhaps
and intelligence and all sorts of things
that make successful make us very
successful social primates
so the adaptations that are associated
with bipedalism have taken a great toll
on our skeleton from the very from our
from our crania all the way down to our
toes and all of those have unintended
consequences in a sense
so we have
faces that are tucked up under our
brains and have incredible antarctic
skulls have all this curvature we have
an s-shaped spine in order to stand over
our center of gravity we have um we are
a biped so our knees angle in and that
puts a lot of stress on our knees and we
have all of this weight going down into
our feet and ankles and we have all of
these little bones in our feet that have
to support all that weight and all of
these moving parts lead to all sorts of
problems just in terms of being a biped
all by itself
now the fact that we're social animals
means that we have these very large
brains and in order to have these very
large brains you have to give birth to
these large brain babies
and as karen will no doubt be talking
about in a lot more detail
you've got to get a large brained baby
through what has become a pelvic birth
canal and a pelvic birth canal is
necessary having a bony bony canal that
a baby's head has to navigate through is
a byproduct of the bipedal process so
all of these things that are associated
with our great intelligence which makes
us human and our bipedality which makes
us human have all sorts of unpleasant
consequences
then
one of the things that makes human
another thing that makes us human is our
life history pattern so that we have
slowly maturing babies that need a lot
of attention we have um we they grow up
it takes a long time for them to grow up
we don't have we we have in we and well
let's put it this way we have higher we
have we have higher fertility rate than
other primates so we have we have
actually lots of babies and we also live
a lot longer than other primates and
because we live longer a lot of the pro
the problems that are associated with
having their brain and being a biped
affect more and more people and so in a
nutshell those are some of the the
qualities that makes us human that make
us human and
some of the problems that are associated
with them
so we wouldn't win any awards for our
design we're not designed but we've
evolved slowly and
with the benefits have come many of
these issues one of our first questions
was related to that and that comes from
bianca and she says what are what sort
of downsides are there to human
evolution aren't humans pretty well
evolved so what are some more of the
downsides rachel why don't you go ahead
and i mean karen let's go ahead and have
you take a stab at that question well we
have all sorts of problems that come
about as a result of the fact that
evolution has tinkered with our
skeletons
and made them work for the job that
we're doing but with as the question
asked downside so we have problems with
our feet we have
problems with our arches and plantar
fasciitis we have low back pain is one
of the most common ailments
that afflicts people that
at a very high rate um people have
problems with their lower back and my
specialty is we have difficulty giving
birth
birth is a time when um women have to
pass a pretty large baby a very large
brained baby through a narrow passage
and it's a time when
babies and mothers are at risk
they're at risk of injury they're at
risk of dying
and that's because natural selection is
acting at that point in a pretty intense
way
we have another thing that was talked
about in our session was third molar
problems
um many people today have impacted third
molars
which are also a result of our
evolutionary history so-called wisdom
teeth um so we could go on with lots of
lots lots and lots of examples of these
um
the ones the examples that we've given
are skeletal examples but there are also
um other examples some
hemorrhoids to give a graphic one um
this is a painful interview
jar and jen have a question we wondered
if women
disproportionately feel the effects of
changes in the environment their
question is
do women feel the environmental
connection more than men
is especially is their food connection
in other words
do they need to make adaptations to
changes in the environment and diet in
particular are they more susceptible to
changes and need to adapt more to them
that's it i would say certainly it's
just is this for me
yes
either of you
uh i would say that certainly in our
evolutionary history women have been
more impacted by the environment simply
because they need to have
a better nutrition effectively than men
because they need to they're they're
gestating for a large part of their
reproductive life and when they're not
gestating they're lactating they're
either you know carrying these these
babies or they're where they're feeding
them and that takes nutritional
resources and if you don't get it out of
the environment you get it out of the
mother's body so you so women even now
of course our calcium depleted
often after they give birth to babies
and after they nurse babies for a long
time so nutrition is more important that
i would say definitely for women and for
men and so in that sense it i would say
that women are probably more impacted by
environmental changes or have been in
the past
and it's a steady supply of food to feed
that growing brain that larger brain and
we need to make sure that they're very
expensive
we have a question from michael andrades
he asks in what level do you feel human
beings evolving what are the current
pressures that are driving human
evolution nowadays
well disease of course is very important
today now that we live in such high
population densities disease has become
really i think
the major
force of selection acting on
on humans
ever since the neolithic really and
potentially even earlier
and one of the things about most of our
prehistory is that we've lived in
populations with very low population
density and it really hasn't been until
the last 30 000 years which i which i
think is sparked by by decreases in
mortality but only in the last 30 000
years or so where you actually see
populations expanding and this
accelerated like crazy in the neolithic
and when you have with with agriculture
and domestication and so when you see
that happening you have people living in
denser populations you have people
living in contact with animals and
infectious disease became really
important and
as cochrane and harpending have written
in the 10 000 year explosion
that's the time period when evolution is
actually accelerated so it's getting
faster and faster largely because of
these new select these basically these
new disease pressures that are forcing
people to do that
more than ever before in some ways and
also because you have more people living
so that you have more
more more mutations with more people and
more chance for selection to work
so
just to clarify there you're saying that
there's more disease in the last 10 000
years it's because we have larger
populations can you explain that a
little bit and also clarify that's when
we began in the last 10 000 or 30 000
years living longer can you talk about
that a little bit that we began living
longer but what what was the cost of
that as well
okay sure well in the last um
the work that i've done has shown that
that that basically we've had
relatively high mortality rates for most
of human evolution and this is basically
looking at big collections of fossils
from all over the world and for most
until the last thirty thousand years or
so there was sort of an archaic life
history pattern we did very steep
workout mortality curves where people
died really very few people let's put it
this way very few people lived into
older adulthood there would have been
relatively few grand plans
so that for neanderthals for instance
who are living before these modern
humans of the upper paleolithic had for
every 10 young adults in the
who who died you've had you have only
you have four older adults so they're
basically this is saying that very few
people live to be older adults very few
people live to be grandparents
and then about 30 000 years ago you see
an absolute shift in the pattern for
every 10 young people with 20 older
people who died so that more people to
be expected to live longer and live to
be long enough to be old enough to be
grandparents and once you have people
living longer they live long enough to
have more children just by themselves so
their fertility will go up
and
once you have older people around who
can help take care of grandchildren etc
you can help the survivorship of those
older people those
of those young people and your
children's families and all of those
things together can will help will cause
populations to expand and then there's
archaeological evidence
that supports that
so about in the upper paleolithic about
30 000 years ago you see evidence of
populations growing
and in the neolithic at 10 000 years ago
when you have domestication you have a
whole lot of evidence of populations
growing even more and what happens then
in the neolithic is you have people
settling down settling
close to one another in close contact
with animals and of course if you look
at diseases from the perspective of the
pathogen
they want
dense populations so they can move from
post to host to host and it's it's in
their best interest of course to have
people living close to one another and
so once that environment exists
then the pathogens have all sorts of
evolutionary advantages and they can
take off so when you have
large numbers of people living together
with dense populations it's great for
those
um
those little microorganisms that cause
all our diseases then we in turn have to
develop a resistance to those
and that's where the selection comes
from largely modern
yes it totally makes sense and we think
it's a great thing to live to be older
but then we also heard yesterday bruce
latimer talk about how our backs
uh and our knees and hips are good for
maybe 40 50 years if we're lucky but
then we're on our own after that so
we're living to be older but then we
start having all sorts of our design
failures don't work our bodies start to
design they're not designed beyond that
can you talk about that as well
sure i mean
it's true we're not designed beyond that
i mean there's sort of two there's two
interrelated things here we're not all
that well designed in the first place i
mean as we as as bruce and jerry talked
about yesterday you know we have all
sorts of problems with our back who
would design a back that looks like ours
who would design feet that looked like
ours if we were just trying to be
efficient but the problem is is that all
of those things and it can be
problematic for young people as well but
all of these things get much worse when
you become older
largely
for many reasons but partially for
instance for reasons of osteoporosis the
reason osteoporosis gets worse of course
as you get older you lose bone density
with age and this can contribute to a
lot of these problems
also you um
you also your muscles become weaker with
age you lose muscle fibers and you can
lose for instance striated muscle fibers
in the urethra which causes urinary
incontinence you lose your muscle
strength in the pelvic floor which can
cause
prolapse and uh and you also lose uh
some of the
the muscles that uh
you lose the the muscle function that
holds a lot of your um your body
together so the paper clips and duct
tape that that jerry talked about
yesterday uh will
will
will start to fail
as you get older so those are all
problematic things and of course up
until 30 000 years ago you didn't have a
lot of people living to be older
and so it was not a big problem it's
certainly a big problem
karen maybe tell us a little more about
childbirth too
uh it's is it so difficult for other
species of primates to give birth to
babies or is this a result of our
brilliant adaptations of a big brain and
upright walking talk to us a little bit
about
why we have such a time a tough time
with why we're so lucky to have a tough
time with childbirth and why wouldn't
why wouldn't that not why would that
survive if so many women die in
childbirth
why would we still be giving birth to
such big brain babies why would there be
any of us left do that
um so birth in humans is really
different from birth and other primates
um our closest relatives chimpanzees and
other um great eggs seem to have a
pretty easy time the baby is much
smaller than the the passage that it has
to pass through and it passes through
pretty easily and without um without
having to twist and turn but in humans
the baby just barely fits through and it
can really only go through pretty much
one way and so it has to twist and turn
so that the baby's head constantly finds
the the longest axis of the birth canal
and that and because the birth canal is
shaped so that the cross section is
different at different parts of the
birth canal the baby's head has to turn
and twist and the shoulders also
represent an important obstacle so for
humans birth is complicated
and the baby's head usually emerges from
the mother's body facing away from the
mother so a position that obstetricians
call occiput anterior the occipital back
of the baby's head is to the anterior or
front of the mother's body
and that means all of that means that
human mothers benefit from assistance
from having someone there to help when
they're in labor and that person could
be a midwife or obstetrician or it could
be their sister or their mother or
somebody who is familiar with the birth
process who can do simple things that
can increase the likelihood that the
mother and baby will be okay
and that's quite different from other
from other primates so you might say
well and i should add that um death in
childbirth used to be a commonplace
event for both mothers and infants um
not so many generations ago
pretty much everybody would know a woman
who had died in childbirth and certainly
losing babies um at the time of birth
was very commonplace um so it's a good
question why hasn't natural selection
changed this system so that doesn't
happen
i think that speaks directly to
how advantageous it is for us to have a
large brain
our large brain which as you said right
at the beginning is one of the hallmarks
of being human enables us to have the
complex learned cultural behavior that
is really the
human adaptation it's central to the way
that we make our way in the world
so how about the wisdom teeth what was
the advantage of having the wisdom teeth
that third molar and why are we losing
them today we heard a report from alan
mann at the meetings yesterday that a
significant proportion of the population
has a genetic
mutation that is there being born
without this third molar without them
the wisdom teeth it's still a smaller
proportion of the population but it's
beginning to happen
well i will tell you that even as we
speak right now i have a wisdom tooth
that's poking into the side of
i personally have third molar genesis on
one side of my
my jaw both on both upper and lower jaw
and i have my wisdom teeth that have
been continuously erupting for many many
many years now
for for ages so i think lots of people
have trouble with their wisdom teeth and
i think it's a great example actually of
ongoing evolution i think the i what
allen's point was yesterday was that
having wisdom teeth once our jaws start
to reduce and he made a point of it
being having our
or basically being having our faces
tucked up under our brains just having
that shift shortens your face but also
compounded with that are things like
cooking and other things that have make
your jaws
that basically have helped
have allowed our jaws to get smaller our
faces to get smaller uh has meant that
there hasn't been enough room in our
mouth for all of our teeth
effectively so we've been losing our
third molars
and
we're in the process of doing that it's
been a scar of human evolution because
and because when it's impacted it can
cause all sorts of problems impacted
wisdom teeth can in fact kill you it's
not just a matter of reproduction which
was pointed out a lot by allen but
having an impacted wisdom tooth can lead
to abscesses and lead to infections that
can that can can actually be fatal
and it can also of course cause a lot of
pain that can reduce your fertility as
alan said there's you know i think isn't
it sorry
well i think in
in our society we tend to think of
dental problems as relatively benign but
in a in an environment where you don't
have access to medical care and you
don't have antibiotics
dental problems can kill you
so it can be very serious and of course
it can impede your reproductive success
so we're in the process there's a
we're in the process of losing our third
motors there have been mutations
apparently that have um that have caused
third molar genesis that have caused
those last teeth not to calcified
and uh and this these mutations have
spread because they're beneficial
and so you see more and more people now
who have whose third molars simply don't
develop
and there are other
examples of this i think in the primate
world the calatricidae those little the
little south american monkeys that have
no third molars their tiny tiny little
monkeys and they also have you know
they're
the other new world monkeys like all uh
anthropoids have three
molars but those little tiny south
american monkeys only have two
and so this could very likely be a
process that was quite similar
so to put you really on the spot can you
explain how how having pain in your
wisdom teeth might impede our
reproduction alan mann gave a great
example at the meeting i think it's a
great story about having how pain might
have a reproductive impact
well
well
allen argued that um
he told a little story made a little
scenario of a person who has a very sore
jaw from um from having an impacted
wisdom tooth and he said their partner
suggests the way he put it was about a
reproduction
and the person with the sore jaw says
i'm sorry not tonight honey my tooth
hurts too much
um so that was his that was his scenario
um but i think the possibility of um
of infection is another thing that
you know really needs to be considered
so i think both are
are are important
and then we had a a talk also we had a
speaker talking about the foot and ankle
we haven't discussed that as much we've
talked about the back and reproduction
talk about the foot when we began
walking upright
we had a foot that was designed for it
had been a hand basically it had been
progressed i may have a foot that really
looks a lot like a hand we sometimes say
other primates are four-handed um and
humans are very distinctive in um in our
feet because our big toe has moved over
to be aligned with the rest of our toes
and the foot has become
something that bears all the weight of
the body um so there's been a lot of
modifications and um jerry talked a lot
about how many bones there are in the
foot um and how um he kept well rachel
already quoted he he said that the foot
looks like something that was put
together with duct tape and paper clips
um that it's not really the kind of foot
an engineer would design
and he actually talked about the kind of
foot that an engineer did design when he
talked about some of these prosthetic
devices that um that that individuals
have uh have today um so
our foot which
isn't well designed um is subject to all
kinds of problems um that are
that come from the fact that we're
bipedal but he talked about um plantar
fasciitis he talked about um
fallen arches
about um bunions and about
and
fibular fractures
lower um fractures of the ankle which
are much more common in um in comets
than in great apes
so that so that the sort of fracture
which does occur in a very small
percentage of apes occurs in a much much
higher percentage of hominids
and i don't know exactly how many feet
there are
that he's looked at but but that
fracture exists in
two
which is a much higher percentage than
you expect to see in any in any age
group so there are
there's there are higher numbers of
fractures all sorts of problems with
feet and also problems just with having
an arch in the foot
so i mean one of the big there's
there's several adaptations of the human
foot i mean we have to have these these
very uh lightweight
bones that
basically absorb a lot of stress the
heel comes down and heel strike and then
we have this arch in our focus sort of
double arch in our foot that is
postulated to basically be a shock
absorber and other people suggest that
it may
basically say maybe
it saves energy for for a long distance
running but it does definitely act as a
shock absorber which is some of the
stuff that bruce latimer has written
about and this in and of itself can
cause a lot of problems if you have flat
feet it can cause stress fractures and
all sorts of other things
you
don't get into the army right with flat
feet and things like that so uh so there
are all sorts of problems that can be
associated with our foot structure
and i thought one thing that he was
talking about that i thought was really
interesting and important is that some
of the things that we
talk about might be argued to be um side
effects of our modern lifestyle right so
some things people have said well that's
because people wear shoes and they walk
on pavement
and they you know they they are living a
different lifestyle than our ancestors
but what jerry's shown is that some of
these um problems go back long before
the modern lifestyle and they probably
were present as soon as people started
walking upright
but one thing that nobody talked about
really was that those problems are also
compounded when people became larger
because the earliest biped with
blackheads would have been quite small
lucy was small and the early
australopithecines were small so
bipedalism was sort of the problems of
bipedalism compounded with larger body
size you would think and also
of course living longer
we have a question related to this it's
perfect for this from bianca
that is how could we have evolved better
are there any obvious fixes to the
common issues that all
that that all humans have
um
and she asks also does the evolution
follow the path of least resistance and
as i ask this i'm thinking what jeremy
de silva said
that you know he brought up the case of
the ostrich foot
and
the idea was that five million years
hasn't been long enough to make the
perfect foot for humans that ostriches
have had
65 million years or a lot 230 million
years to come up with a better design
foot for running
upright um
so this is an interesting question could
we have evolved better is it that we've
had not had enough time are we evolving
better are there are there
obvious fixes
okay let's take that on thanks or this
idea of perfection um so evolution isn't
a process that has a direction that's
moving towards some kind of ultimate
perfection
natural selection is a process that
tinkers with the system that we
inherited from our ancestors and does
the best for that particular set of
environmental circumstances um with the
material that it's got
so um so it isn't
and it's always a balance of conflicting
constraints i mean we see this very
obviously in the pelvis when we talk
about childbirth too um too narrow a
pelvis is obviously um too small a
pelvis is obviously disadvantageous for
having babies but if the pelvis is too
big then it's disadvantageous for
walking so and that's true of everything
that there's a trade-off um and so i
don't think that
it's right to say that evolution is
moving towards perfection or that we
should ever expect to have something
that's perfectly designed
we have another question here from paul
can you talk a bit about how these
design flaws and inefficiencies
counter the arguments of intelligence
design intelligent design proponents
well i think that in a sense all of
these do i mean you would think that if
if there was
if there was an intelligent designer
who
was omniscient
you we could all design better systems
but the fact that we don't have it in a
sense refutes that to some extent
if if
the evolutionary process of course could
be a product of design i mean that that
a notice known as we don't i don't think
we want to
get into a situation where we think
where we're saying that
that evolutionary science refutes the
existence of god which we which i think
neither of us believes at all
but i do think that you could argue that
there is no
there is no um
that if you were going to design a
system
a vibe if you were going to design a
large brain bypass you would probably
decide an engineer was going to do it
they would do it
that way and so evolution as karen just
said we'll work with with the material
that it has
so that it
it's going to work with the ancestral
format and as environments change and as
circumstances change it will modify a
lot of the the
the organism would become modified so
that it will be able to reproduce in
that particular environment it doesn't
have to be perfect it just has to work
for the environment that that organism
is in during the lifetime of that
individual and those and those things
that allowed it to have babies
to the next generation so it's not a
it's not a system of perfection and also
the the environment itself is always a
changing target
so the circumstances when the
circumstances change then what's best
changes
so we can't have uh blade runner feet
and legs
we have a new question here danielle
cook asks what about spandrel traits
i wish they'd addressed some of the
accidental traits that have occurred
okay the spandrel traits come from
steven j gould's uh famous paper the
spaniels of san marco
where the uh where where the uh
the the spanish in in gothic
architecture the little
well
little spaces right the little spaces
that are left over
the unintended spaces that are left over
don't really have function they're just
there because they're an accident of the
design of other aspects of the design so
they're they're just there that are left
over and there are and there's a very
good argument that could be made that
that when we look at our bodies not
everything we don't need to look at
everything in terms of adaptation there
are a lot of folks who would argue that
certainly plyotrophy or cleotrophy that
has been discussed
i guess discussed a little bit in in
yesterday's symposium would be an
example that if one gene is under
selection
any gene that's linked with it will also
come under selection so that kind of
linkage would definitely be an example
of a spandrel trait
and so
i'm trying to think right now in terms
of the birth process an example it would
be from what what rachel was talking
about actually would be sort of that the
debate that
has been going on about why do we live
so long right so you could give two
different explanations um one of which
would be you could say that having
people live into very old age was itself
an adaptation because and that's what
the grandmother hypothesis proposes that
that when women live a long time they're
able to help their their own children to
reproduce by taking care of their
grandchildren so that would be an
adaptationist kind of argument and then
the spandel argument would be that old
age evolved as a byproduct of other
aspects of changes in our life's life
like lengthening adolescence you know
childhood or something like that or you
could think of it in terms of men is
menopause itself under selection so we
we are menopausal was menopause itself
under selection as some folks think or
was menopause for instance a spandrel a
consequence of basically an unintended
consequence a byproduct of living
so that would be another plus
we also um had another session with bill
leonard's talk where you read that for
him and he got into some life history
questions the kind of things you're
talking about now
where we have different groups of people
uh adapting different environments with
different kinds of diets and
and we got into that a little bit could
you talk about how that is a different
kind of scar of human evolution
right um
bill's paper was basically about obesity
and the problems of obesity and we've
had you know we've had a
long history of being hunter-gatherers
and having a and basically having a very
different kind of lifestyle than we have
today we have all these these
adaptations for successfully
metabolizing food and storing excess
energy as fat
and people who are good at that were
very successful in
in earlier periods of our existence
because they were really able to store
fat for for
for
for
periods
and there was there were less resources
around but now people who are very well
adapted to storing these these
basically who are well adapted to to
converting glucose that are
disadvantaged because we have everything
so that's one part of his is his story
but the other part is is that
traditionally we we do a lot more
exercise
basically and that was the main point of
what he wanted to say
is that a lot of people are focused
obviously the obesity epidemic is caused
by people eating too much
and converting that to fat and not
having enough physical activities to
burn it off so that there's an equation
basically of the energy you're ingesting
and the energy you're
expending
and and you're out of balance and that's
why we have this obesity epidemic we
tend to focus a lot on how much we're
eating and the super-sized knee
phenomena and all of that so we tend to
focus a whole lot on how much we eat and
what bill was trying to point out
yesterday is that is really important
and there are populations that are
really well adapted who were well
adapted in the past to converting all
this into fact and they are even more
disadvantaged and the argues that the
physical side of this the exercise side
has been
ignored and that we should be paying
more attention to that and that we could
even we could have even moderate
physical activity levels that would um
that would circumvent that so the scar
of human evolution here is that we are
well we
that those folks who were once well
adapted
to converting energy into storage are
now disadvantaged and it's become a scar
that's very interesting the case where
the adaptation made sense at one time
but no longer does and the difference
between the environment has changed
because the environment
so in a way that's the way we're
evolving now because the environment is
changing yeah
yeah and we have new questions here
that's interesting go ahead
uh the new question is pablo salinas has
a question the scientific and
technological before i ask the question
i want to remind viewers to please post
their questions at the bottom of the
page all right make sure they put them
put them in down there
uh the new question from pablo is do the
scientific and technological
developments
are they aimed at eradicating faults due
to the evolutionary development
or leave open the control loops i'm
sorry i'm having a little trouble
understanding that let's see do the
scientific and technological
developments are they aimed at
eradicating faults
i mean i wouldn't say that
if i understand the question i'm not
sure i do but i would say that um
scientific and technological innovations
are aimed at improving quality of life
um right we don't think
we don't think when we're inventing
machines we're not thinking about our
evolutionary
um
future or anything like that so it's not
it's not aimed at making evolutionary
changes
i'm not sure
it's
i guess it's getting at the sort of the
question of whether medicine
is it actually is maladaptive all the
problems of evolution does it leave open
the control loops does it doesn't make
the problems worse i mean it kind of
gets maybe at that question
i mean
it may it certainly changes the way
natural selection is operating i mean to
use an example from my work um cesarean
section means that
women in countries with good medical
technology and i emphasize that that's a
not that's certainly a small um
proportion of the world but that they
have they're able to have babies even
though
in another situation they might not be
able to have a baby because they're um
for example their pelvis is too small to
allow successful passage of a of a
newborn so um in that sense technology
has changed the way that selection is
working um
and and that's certainly i would expect
would have consequences certainly people
um survive today with all kinds of um of
problems that would that would have you
know
our vision for example um
that that would have been impossible in
the past
and you were talking and you're you were
giving some interesting statistics
during your talk about cesarean sections
how much they're on the increase i think
you said in the united states 30 of all
births now
are due to c-sections and in countries
like italy forty percent maybe you can
tell if you think about
brazil
cesarean section rates are up to fifty
percent in some places um so
why do people get cesarean sections well
um for a whole range of reasons um
sometimes it's for the convenience of
doctors um alarmingly to me it's often
because women think that that's an
easier way to have a baby and they
actually have an elective cesarean
section um sometimes it's for cosmetic
reasons sometimes it's a hedge against
liability
and so this rate of 50 is just i think
astronomically high but the world health
organization actually came out with a
recommendation for what they think the
target caesarean section rate should be
and that rate was 12
and what i think they mean by that is
that
um is that we should of course there are
some situations where um if we don't do
a caesarean section the life of the baby
or the life of the mother or both are
really in
at
risk in danger and in
at some point it becomes very important
um for us to be able to do them and so
they recommend that doing about 12
of births as caesarean sections is a a
sort of appropriate target
um right are necessary right right
wow
that's incredible
was there anything else either of you
wanted to mention out of the out of the
uh talks yesterday or the conversation
about our scars of evolution
that have been emerging
well
um
questions and meantime readers or
viewers not readers should go ahead and
post questions at the bottom of the page
we could send questions this is why
i think that
i think it's the whole story i think
that what's what's
what's
you know this the the symposium that we
put together
comes from is was based on a 1951
article in scientific america
and by wilton crow and people have been
thinking about this really for a long
time but yet it sort of hasn't take cut
it hasn't
it hasn't taken it hasn't taken off and
i think that people have a tendency to
think of the evolutionary process as one
that is driven towards perfection and
don't really think about the uh not i
shouldn't even see the side effects of
it but the imperfections of it and the
trade-offs that we we have to that we
make all the time or that biology has
made and so the many of the things that
we sort of deal with are products of the
evolutionary process certainly not
something that's leading towards
perfection but something that is
workable
workable now and maybe you know in the
future may be better adapted or worse
adapted and we have no real way of
knowing um actually one thing that matt
cartmelt one of our discussions brought
up was that it's not just humans who
have scars of evolution you can look at
lots and lots of different species and
he gave probably 10 or 15 wonderful
examples
um where you can see in the structure or
physiology of an animal um traces of its
evolutionary history so um why do blood
vessels run a certain way or
why do animals are animals at risk of
choking or a whole range of things and
so having scars
of or
having legacies of our evolutionary
history that are kind of imperfections
is not something unique to humans what i
would say but he didn't say this but i
would say is that it may be that because
humans are cultural animals that were
able to ameliorate the effects of some
of them
um so so
they exist in all species i i can't
imagine how it could happen that they
wouldn't exist but um it may be that
humans um
because we're able to deal with them
through cultural
um
behaviors through technology that may
change the way that they appear
we have two more some more questions
coming in here i've got a question from
linda
populations can intermingle far more
readily nowadays what is the likely
impact of this on our evolution
uh
uh i think it
i think it has had a huge impact on our
evolution
fundamentally what it's meant in the
last and probably for a very long time
now is that we have no races and that's
a very it's a sort of an interesting
thing we are really unusual one of the
things that's most unusual about people
is that we are a widespread mammalian
species that actually has this that is
very that has very little subdivision
so that we so that genetically we're
much more similar within population
where much more most of our variation
occurs within populations
this is very unusual so that if you have
if you look at bears you know they
basically have different
uh you can have different subspecies of
bears going across the world you know
many different populations of gray
wolves are very self-divided but humans
have very little variation between
populations
and it could be i mean there are two
ways of living this this could be a
product of our entire evolutionary
history it could be that for a very long
time there's always been this
interconnection between human population
or it could be that this is a product of
very very recent human evolution but we
do have some evidence right that
in the past archaic humans were much
more subdivided we have subspecies like
neanderthals neanderthals clearly were
interbreeding with modern humans so we
would consider those the same species
they would really be sub species as we
think of as we would think of subspecies
and as race was once defined
but since we've had populations
expanding i would say actually for a
long time uh since populations have
expanded and exchanged genes we've
basically been losing those
separations between groups of people so
that we now are and and this is of
course accelerated over the last century
as people become much more more
interconnected so that we now actually
have no racial distinctions which is a
very interesting thing and i'd say it's
something that makes humans unique i've
always thought of that along with our
unique life history patterns as being
some of the most two of the most
important aspects of being a modern
human what does it really mean to be a
modern human and one of it is that we
have no races and the second is that we
live a long time and both of those
things i think are interrelated and
actually
play to the actual meaning of what it is
to be
a modern human
and so i think the fact that our
populations have expanded have just
and that we integrate even more is
basically just the latest in a long a
long time trend of human
interbreeding very interesting
we have a question from tashkego does it
seem to you that because humans are the
most recent addition to the story of
life that increasing complexity and
capability is a direction in the
universe since the big bang is there
increasing complexity in human evolution
i would not say that
uh there's certainly increasing cultural
complexity for sure
but uh you know it that's a very
anthropocentric way of looking at things
we're not really the most recent
thing in evolution there's been lots of
think of all those organisms that have
that are very recently evolved that have
recently speciated we're seeing new
diseases of course emerge all the time
you knew insects emerging so i wouldn't
say that we are the we're the most
recent
thing to have evolved
in terms of our lineage we are the most
recent obviously but that doesn't
necessarily mean that we're most complex
again there's no direction to evolution
and basically
we adapt as well as we can to the
environment we do adapt culturally as
karen says and certainly we have adapted
cultural evolution as has become
incredibly complex but that's not
necessarily a reflection of our
biological evolution and cultural
complexity is caused by all sorts of
things
including demography including
including the number of people that we
have and the interaction between those
people and it's an exa and it and it is
an acceleration
i'd say
i have another question and you began
you answered this already a little bit
when you talked about matt cartwheel
pointing out that other species also
have evolutionary scars hashtag want to
know are there other species that have
as many or comparable levels of
evolutionary scars or do we have more
because of the kinds of dramatic
adaptations we've made are there others
that are probably
painfully scarred
i think it's kind of hard to quantify
um you know you i don't know that we
could really go through and count the
number of scars i think that as i said i
think it's possible that we
are able to
mitigate the effects of things in ways
that other animals can't but certainly
when we think about the kinds of things
that that matt cardinal was talking
about all species had those
because all species got to where they
are today through a process of evolution
in which natural selection was working
with the raw material that was provided
by their evolutionary legacy
do either of you speak spanish
no no sadly
yeah i'm not going to read the spanish
question to you then maybe i'll get
somebody to translate
we have another question here does any
uh we have a question here could you
discuss the fact that the large brain
exists in spite of its relatively
limited use
in other words evolution has apparently
not devolved the brain
which should have happened according to
a to its use it or lose it theory i
guess the point there is that we're not
using all aspects of the brain so it
shouldn't be so big
um
a little outside of your area perhaps
i think we are using our big brains um
i mean i think that
i think if
i think that our big brains are very
advantageous because and we know that
partly because of the high costs that
are associated with them right they're
energetically costly it takes a lot to
grow them takes a lot to feed them and
then they're obstetrically costly
so i think that
that the advantages that come to us
in terms of complexity of behavior
complexity of social relationships um
that come to us by having a large brain
outweigh those costs
that i mentioned
i think the spanish question i'm going
to roughly translate it myself basically
says
could biotechnology come up with
effective solutions
um
basically i think for our species to
sort of help
heal these scars i think it's kind of
like
doing that all the time that's what yeah
those artificial prosthetic feet are
that's what
cesarean section is even though we do it
more than um than we need to um that's
that's what glasses are that's um all
sorts of um antibiotics
i mean
also to go on to to uh
to interfere with the process of
evolution or to improve it that was the
other aspect of that question i think
you did address that already to a degree
with the role of medicine it does it can
address that another question here
austin dunbar
there was the comment of caesareans
about how science affects evolution
you're on a roll here expanding on that
or advances in medical science
potentially damaging to the genetic pool
so this is again the same kind of
question
well it's a that's an old it's been that
that's been something that's been
discussed for a long time it was
actually discussed a lot in the eugenics
literature the idea that if you actually
keep people alive is medicine good or
bad
if you keep people alive who are
effectively weak are you actually
weakening the gene pool
and i think
in a way that's you're
one of the things that makes us human
makes us unique is that we have this
culture and that this is a part we are
able to do these sorts of things and so
and we basically create our own
environment to a large extent so there
isn't some perfect strength there isn't
some sort of perfect strong human that
that strength is basically what we
consider strong is a is culturally
determined to a large extent right now
we don't think that it's a terrible
thing to we don't think we don't there's
no stigma associated with
with not being able to see well there's
no stigma associated with not being
whole for instance but just a couple of
generations ago there was
and it would have been then many people
then would have said but you're really
weakening the gene pool if you
give people glasses or if you give
people artificial limbs and things like
that uh but uh but i think that we
as a species where our plasticity comes
from our culture and we're able to
change that environment and so that it's
no longer
it's no longer necessarily a negative
thing because that culturally is what
i'm trying to say and i would say i
would say also that um
physicians aren't physicians are
thinking about the health and welfare of
their patients not and
of people who are alive today and not
about um the evolutionary success of our
lineage and that's as it should be
but i would say even if they
tried to think about the evolutionary
success they would fail
because the environment is changing and
we have no way of knowing what's going
to be advantageous
10 000 years from now but in a sense we
control our environment so much i mean
our environment is in to such an extent
man-made that those things that were
deleterious in the so-called natural
world whatever that is
are is those things are not deleterious
today is the point that i was trying to
make so that if you if so that wearing
glasses now you can correct your vision
it doesn't matter and it doesn't matter
if you if you if you don't have great
vision and it's not going to affect our
evolutionary history because we've
created an environment that it's not
that doesn't make that important is that
if that makes sense
totally i mean in a world with blade
runners in wheelchairs
vision of what we're adapting in
different ways so it's changing our view
of what is
what is uh
a successful adaptation so it's a very
important just caution
just make one caution that of course
those cultural fixes for problems are
not universally available that's right
they're available in to some people in
parts of the world that's right
right
exactly and they're not biologically
inherited
so yeah good point
um
at least if i have any more questions
here
in bill leonard's talk
he talked about obesity and he talked
about exercise he also talked that there
are a lot of people that are trying to
look back to evolution to go back to
reconstruct things like the paleo diet
to try to go back to evolution to look
for tips on how to live today
but but one of the ideas that came up
was that there were many different
adaptations in the past that there have
been many many many ways to
adapt to different environments and
just as
the the subtext to that is that there
have been many different ways to evolve
um
maybe many not many many
perhaps not many different human forms
but different fixes to different
problems in the environment and also
with our anatomy um if you look at
different hominin hominids over time
there have been probably different
slight differences in the anatomy so i'm
wondering if you can address that as
well that you know this has been a
process
of tinkering along over millions of
years and that continues
actually i think this is something that
steven j gould used to write about very
very beautifully
about sort of the the fact that the way
things happen
in evolutionary history
need not have been that it could have
happened another way very easily because
to use the term that he used um
historical events and the evolution or
evolutionary events are contingent on
very small details of circumstances or
potentially small details so there's no
sense in which
we are the inevitable outcome of the
evolutionary process it could have
happened very differently
um and so
so i think that that's an important
thing to think about that and that does
contribute to this idea that we're not
that that evolution isn't a progressive
process of increasing perfection
and and one of the things i think in
terms of the fossil record that's just
that in the last few years is really
coming up are the different ways of
being bipedal i think that you know the
the art epithecus remains are are really
amazing we always thought about validity
as always being terrestrial black
fidelity and always being obligated by
him and now with artie you see
a very different kind of a different
sort of morphology that that is
associated with this kind of bipedality
and also then with sadiva remains where
you have this this this very different
foot structure for uh for or somewhat
different foot structure for a biped
that suggests that there may have been
some sort of a different sort of way of
being bipedal even within
australopithecines
and it's a it's it's a very interesting
thing because we it's it's great because
it always makes it makes you realize how
little we know about the actual details
of the evolutionary process of always
being
challenged and surprised by
all these different ways of being here
it's the monty python ministry of silly
walks that we started yeah right exactly
we have another question here from linda
uh epigenetics is emerging as an
important new field how is that
affecting our understanding of human
evolution that's a rather broad question
but if there's a way you can
come at that from what you do that would
be great is epigenetic genetics
affecting um
the scars of human evolution in any way
or the study of anatomy uh in the past
of the way we interpret some of the
anatomy and fossils in particular
i am involved our forms today in the way
that we're thinking about anatomy but it
certainly affects the way we think about
evolution right that we understand now
how much the environment affects
you know the evolutionary process at
many different levels not just at the
level that darwin understood but at um
at other levels as well
and it's brought focus it's brought
brought focus on development which is so
important because that's the key to
understanding complexity so i think it's
i think it's great i'm not sure that
it's affecting and i'm sure that it
affects scars of human evolution but i'm
not sure that it's affecting the
anatomical scars that we're looking for
or or we're just at the beginning of
understanding how right exactly
i guess the expression of genes and
development uh what would affect that
and understanding it and living
organisms that might help you interpret
what happened in the past
well there'll be some time on that we
have another question here from tashkego
does evolution show a record of
increasing amounts of energy spent upon
child rearing that would be a good
question for you too
um any idea about that
well we did spend a lot of energy on
child hearings
and in your work as well certainly
certainly um
sarah hurdy i think has written about
this beautifully about the you know we
give birth to babies that are relatively
um
immature at birth and that stay
juvenile dependent on their parents for
a long time
um
i sometimes tease my students about how
long they stay dependent on their
parents but that means that we are
investing a lot of energy in
in our children to make sure that they
grow up to be successful and what hertes
pointed out is that that's a group
effort
um that we're cooperative breeders and
we invest in each other's children as
well as our own
so i think it's it's clear that humans
put a very very high investment in
in our children
i just thought of a scar of human
evolution associated with epigenetics oh
good i think
chris i'm thinking of chris kozawa's
work with um
sweeper they've been looking at
the
the impact of stress during pregnancy
on later development of heart disease
basically and so they're looking at
basically how race and poverty
by affecting pregnancy and perfecting a
woman's pregnancy can lead to
some of the chronic diseases that you
see later in life
and that i think would be an example and
i don't i i didn't i don't have to work
in front of me but it would be a great
example really of the scars and
revolution
what do you have for the epigenetic
process in and of itself
has caused causes damages throughout the
life cycle that you wouldn't even think
would be associated with that so it's
actually helped with the mother
affecting an unborn baby
and it can be stressed that's in stress
that you don't even think about that's
incurred during pregnancy that can
affect an unborn baby and channels of
the life cycle way later on
and it's
and i think that that could potentially
be
a scar of humor
that would tie in with some of the
things like the dutch famine study and
the
mothers that have famine or starvation
the effects are even steamed a couple
generations later
so
they're definitely growth trajectories
and a lot of history
events come out of that that's
interesting
yes
um
any readers out there have a last
question to post i think we're about to
wrap up and uh
i want to say now that that tomorrow we
also are going to have another live chat
at 3 p.m eastern time on toxins in the
environment that will be live from the
aaas so any of you who want to know
about toxins in the environment that's a
good one start getting your questions
ready ready you can post them then
and join us for that live chat if we
have any last minute questions we can
maybe take one more we're about to wrap
up here
uh rachel karen you guys have been great
is there anything else you two want to
add is there anything
about the scars of human evolution
or any evolution that you've got to
bring into this
only that that the things that are i
think that are that are the advantages
that we're facing today that we're
living longer and having basically at
least in the industrialized world more
comfortable lives will actually mean
that we'll be played by some of these
scars
the night there are negative side
effects of it as well
and i think just in general um how much
understanding we think we can have of
our biology and our behavior by looking
at our evolutionary paths
thank you so much i'm so glad you guys
were able to join us again
thanks very much that's great and join
us tomorrow at three if you can thank
you very much
viewers who tuned in
this is live from the aaas thanks bye
you